[Music]
hey guys welcome back to top the record
where we talk about whatever we want
I didn't think you were gonna what I
said you made it like you can't anything
to available now anything
well that's crazy how thinning actually
came back out of nowhere oh you thought
it was crazy that that happened well I
knew because of Steve dude people I love
how the Internet's like going like
should this be allowed to happen I'm
like yes talk about it may generate
clicks controversies about who didn't
watch it no I did that's not a good
movie was the movie that we watch thank
you I didn't watch that you think you're
not a good I know sitting is about like
a dystopian future world like sexy thing
but it's like it's like Hunger Games
Hunger Games yeah and the way that they
thin people out the population and so
overpopulated is they take tests and if
you fail the test then you're not
intelligent enough to say in society and
so they thin you it's like how it's like
it's like based on how stressed kids
feel at school taking these like
standardized tests and soon it's like if
somebody wrote this tweet that had me
dying but it was like it was not when
the thenew came up when the first one
came out because he's like so
controversial we're just kind of going
at him but this one random girl wrote
like I love I love the bidding it's like
a documentary about logo Paul's Caroline
I guess like I said I was thinning or
some [ __ ] before you got a fix or
something wasn't really I think so I
don't know I don't want to follow the
guy but there's like a you can see him
running away and the hair kind of lifted
up but he's like bald like on the sides
over here oh I saw someone comment that
on your Instagram when you promoted it
and I liked their car like that
I loved all that they like well they
really love somebody else's joke there
were things I did you know they were
using joke cuz shame oh I didn't know
anything about the movie just the title
I thought it was something about like a
scary movie about something with weight
loss
there is a movie like that that came out
of the 90s called like thinner or
something like oh was it I think maybe I
don't know maybe I'm maybe I just
thought that as a kid you're too thin
society so they kill you off oh no
losing weight is a [ __ ] [ __ ] people
then doing great I was a pattern but I
am at that point now where I'm like if I
lose it I do if I don't I don't care oh
you're over now that's nice because like
you got skinny enough that you don't
care you know I still have all this
stuff you know what I mean but no hell
no that's way too much [ __ ] work and
that's the point it's like if you want
to move past a certain level of fitness
you actually have to do real work cuz I
just been walking age too because our
metabolism just walking slow down like a
mofo cuz like I you know I kind of
pushed into gear and then I dropped a
little more weight and I got a little
more fit but the outcome of that was it
was stressful to do that you know what I
mean so I've done it up to here just
eating relatively healthy and then
walking every day just not stuffing my
face and I got to this point if I want
to go further I actually have to work
out right like [ __ ] that I ate a pizza a
hot dog yesterday and it was so nice
dude you know oh wait you were there but
you know that day we had Fried Chicken I
had diarrhea all day that they have a
real diarrhea dude like wait is that to
do with your weight loss it's just I
don't eat like greasy booze all cuz it's
your body's react differently now yeah I
just don't eat meat fried chicken pizza
when was this over the weekend oh I must
been fun it was I was available
you blame Bart because we he brought it
up out of nowhere he was like sure it
was an impromptu mmm that's nice that's
fun always invite you guys over to ours
always sick it all started when we went
to Huntington Library for the day I
spent the day at the did you were
invited Brandon wasn't invited to
I live right on hunting right they're
going to go originally because it rained
yeah we weren't but you dig we want to
go to the library okay well it's not a
library really it's like an outdoor like
[ __ ] no I know
is this a bit oh you've been yeah it's
beautiful it's like a staple in LA guys
I didn't get to go either we're gonna go
just wait and I didn't go Hey Joe did
you get invited and you declined yeah
but then they did it on the day they did
it on the day than I told them I can't
go it's just us to be choice re
conspiracy they they purposely we're on
a day that was busy [ __ ] you guys what's
your favorite food oh that's hard I can
go without eating well what's your
favorite food of all time
oh so you were like the sitting I could
relate salt that's no there's actually
not anymore you know it's crazy I think
I overdid your food as Walmart yeah salt
and with the sugar like my whole life
and then I started not eating so much
and then now salty food they're like
extra salty to me where it's like do you
see what happens when you ask these
people basic question I know what it is
some tomorrow it's it's karna and say
who go okay we're gonna make carne and
Sulu go and we're Lord of the Botanical
Gardens and you're not invited
it's not a simple question a simple
question is would you like a doughnut
today
hey see we tell me you don't know your
favorite food favorite food oh my god of
course you do YouTube panel and fun and
that's the question and Joe's like
Bolivia let me go wait we've got to go
look at the way you were brought up in
childhood
that's like committing to a [ __ ]
college degree impressive the period of
my life - it's like my taste buds of
them all yeah evolved every just like
how people just say pizza you know
normal human being what's your favorite
food pizza general [ __ ] sausage and
pepperoni bro you're not a food
connoisseur true you should taste his
cooking or don't or don't to have a
favorite food what's your favorite movie
genre action comedy you guys don't you
guys don't know yet Evangelos well no I
had answers to Mike to the questions
that are just like here's your answer
boom here's your answer and you're like
that just sounds like your answers don't
even genuine cuz you're just like oh let
me just give you an answer action comedy
is my favorite and pizza is my favorite
I did between pancakes and pebble
mushroom pizza pineapple mushroom yeah
it's so weird what the [ __ ] did you just
say to me right now please David knock
it out of her just say [ __ ] pineapple
mushroom pizza yeah come at me bro [ __ ]
that's why you were to buy the honey
July right now is red meat for me
steaks specifically rip rip rip eye rip
I stay there well that's fine at least
the answer
jeez it's better Tucker a [ __ ] minute
so you didn't you said no no he said
Karndean so Google and then you just
said yeah no no I was like yeah but then
later on what you guys were talking oh
like she liked me live I think we need
to go back into the pineapple mushroom
Pete thank you what the pineapple on
pizza what oh you dwell on it so hard
David you sure you don't wanna invite me
and weak I'll try it together I never
ever want to try pineapple mushroom
Peter it's not on your pizza
oh yeah you're a pescetarian well no
this is I've always been my favorite
pizza forever like even when I ate like
every meat on the planet or like
mushrooms I like pineapple I never liked
pearl I putting that [ __ ] together
though no how do you know if you've
never tried it because I know what
mushrooms tastes like on a pizza and I
know what pineapples gonna be I like
extra cheese extra pepperoni they taste
amazing together
my favorite piece I just met really me
too
no breakfast meats or pizza meats I
don't like any of those meats no fun
meats I'll bet you're really boring
needs please no but California Pizza
Kitchen dude they're cauliflower crust
pizza is better than the original dough
pizza really like I didn't even know I
was eating some cauliflower [ __ ] you
should just try try Panvel mushroom you
don't even know hey mickey we're not
friends anymore so don't talk to me I
know that David cuz I wasn't invited to
the Huntington because of your pineapple
you know what we did on Saturday what'd
you do i sat in a room with the lights
off and I stared at a wall
yeah so pixel Steve lives lady waits for
our call no you know what else secret
society life just waiting for my friends
to call have you ever had a bell pepper
and pepperoni no cuz yesterday we got
the wrong [ __ ] pizza right the pizza
guy gave us our wrong pizza there was
someone else's and we opened it and it
was just pepperoni and bell pepper and I
was like what the [ __ ]
like I get the supreme where you got and
I was like we got bell pepper and
pepperoni I was like what the [ __ ] just
gets those two things I was picking up a
pizza at one time and we were there like
just before closing so they're like hey
we have this extra pizza cuz the guy
never picked it up do you want it I was
like [ __ ] yeah absolutely another time
yeah yeah I got free pizza oh hell yeah
and then I get home and I open it and it
was just no it's [ __ ] just onions
yeah onion pizza it wasn't just onions
it was like barbecue sauce instead of
people's like barbecue sauce its enemies
Azaz and onions open up your pizza there
was mushroom in pineapple and then
because our trash wasn't completely full
yet it was like a borderline socials and
in the fridge forever
right so and then when and then when I
had to throw it away I had to take out
the trash so who really want I [ __ ]
took a big L on the biggest L I don't
get the barbecue sauce pizza thing man I
mean I can't do it
well that's EPK one's pretty good we can
all agree on that yes the barbecue sure
you had tomatoes on pizza
yes margherita pizza BAM yeah I like it
cuz I recently got a calzone and then I
just only got Tomatoes and pepperoni and
cheese you know what's good in a calzone
just avocado yeah David [ __ ] you your
toilet must be a disaster it's not the
living hell I'm very regular once a day
it's very fast and it's a dirt all over
like shrapnel to me
you know what I swear I need to correct
the record right now okay so I'm
probably a year ago I mentioned that
Nikki's toilet is like like black we've
talked about the alien black really I
don't remember then we've talked about
this before what boom what but then we
moved right so now we're at a new place
and your toilets like that no my
telephone oh yeah and and her toilet is
completely white like it's whiter than
than than teeth you know I mean it's
[ __ ] beautiful so what I would like
to rescind my comments that Nikki taking
to the same dumps it was it was the
twins it was the toilet it was like
whatever the water was back told him
that he didn't believe I was dead give
it three years and see what happens I
used to think that Nikki took nightmares
shits and now I take that [ __ ] no we
have separate bathrooms we don't do any
any of that stuff together no never
never
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] is like when the other
person's around I do Bart and Gio do
that the first time I was ever on JK
they talked about it and I was like I
cannot believe that I pee and then just
goes hold I got a piece though and then
she doesn't let me flush as she sits on
top of the toilet piece after I pee
she is so frugal that is like really
deep conversations about like what I
gotta pee I got a p2 so like we're
talking still and I'm like talking to
her then she switches and she talks and
she flushes his [ __ ] like I'll be
cooking in the kitchen and [ __ ] she's
like peeing and like we're talking yeah
sexy but I just don't like wiping in
front of him that's kind of like this is
an intimate moment go away that's how
Kim feels but I don't care how is this
walking I mean she doesn't [ __ ] in front
of me and I don't [ __ ] have fun I don't
like even changing and Stan I don't like
changing cuz it's like private like it's
like I I love would like to present
every gotta love that [ __ ]
I love it yeah I always wake up exactly
when she's changing that's true it's a
man
she was it's open put those clothes on
girl Jen asleep but dead like you could
not wake this man up like you're like
like he's snoring I'm like she stopped
snoring it was just like and then I take
off my shirt and he's like you know how
come you don't want him to look at you
changing that's like that's like the
man's greatest joy
I don't know cuz I just feel like I
don't know like sometimes I feel bloated
a lot of times I feel bloated we're not
thinking about that at all but bloated
you know I'm saying yeah and now so is
my dick yeah hell yeah he's waiting for
that opportunity were like he gets a
nipple or a little bit or like ya know
she sent myself she gets all latter-day
saints when we're at home I don't know
why nobody looks at you you were trying
to [ __ ]
no I'll be changing and I'll purposely
try to do like you know yeah something
like you know but then he's just like on
his phone I get distracted so easy dude
oh yeah so you could just be like
changing a hair pitting am i studying
naked yeah what are you doing a mine huh
let me at all last [ __ ] hairpin
whatever I got a so upset I will always
try to parlay in the getting land always
that's not last night dude
no in the morning though he has to get
all clean like I don't you in
spontaneous morning first no not
happening in the Li mo green house
that's about keeping it like we're
dating always yeah but I'm just like
spontaneous I don't want you now and
what you know and it's like 45 minutes
get ready sadly we don't have to kiss
morning sex only works with spooning for
me we're I'm like we don't have to smell
each other's morning breath I have to I
have to bring us not been well he's so
tall that he goes like way over here
like you know he's not gonna smell
anything okay okay we'll let him look at
you make it change that's like well not
sometimes if I'm feeling myself I found
feeling myself then I'll be like okay I
see him looking about that's what he's
sleeping no but like suppose the time I
like I have Candida and it was like I
was just feeling really bloated and I
just like it's not I also can't data
thing yet Tyrael that was gross it's
like a yeast in your gut that makes you
bloated all those I oh yeah yeah like
feeds off of carbs sugar like think I
had that too yeah I was constantly
blowing it hard to get rid of but you
probably like the apples have a cider
vinegar like helps a lot I just cut out
like bread and [ __ ] and then like and
then and my bloat went away okay you
don't drink so the drinking is really
what keeps me from getting rid of this
because there's constant yeast in carb
or some short no it's sugar yeah yeah so
the sugar feeds the yeast and so like
every time I try to get rid of at get so
close but then I have one drink you
can't even have one drink so and it was
during when we went to Vegas that was
when I was like get
rid of it so I was like a bit like at
the end of two weeks of not drinking or
like I can't not drink in Vegas yeah
but anyway so I just feel like I'm sexy
and like even if your husband's feels
like you're always saying ya know it
doesn't matter what he feels what I just
what he's just looking at your titties
and not your belly it's but it doesn't
matter cuz I don't feel sexy so I feel
like even if he says god damn okay it's
like this when I was a kid I well I
still in very pigeon-toed and but I was
pigeon-toed in a self unselfish and
people would watch me while I was
walking and they would make fun of me
after I passed them like they would make
fun of the way I was walking and stuff
and like that I didn't have any friends
when I was younger because they all made
fun of the way I walk whatever we don't
have to go down that road obviously your
own way but my point being is now after
years of correcting it whenever I have
to walk past a group of people
especially guys they're staring at me
and I get but for different reasons now
but I in my head they're looking at the
way I'm walking and so like I like I
also didn't forget how to walk yeah and
I'm like like stiff walking and I'm like
oh [ __ ] they're still looking and
they're probably they're definitely not
looking up the way I'm walking oh I
never said they're trying to picture you
naked right but in my head they're just
looking at the way I'm walking because
I'm so traumatized by Wow and so that's
the same thing with him is like I know
he's probably not looking at the bloat
that I'm seeing but in my head that's
all I can think about that I don't look
at when I look at women like if I find
like you know we're walking or some [ __ ]
and I see like a woman I don't picture
her naked I picture her sitting on a
board of a fortune 500 company
[Laughter]
because I'm a good guy one of the good
ones that's what I do
mm-hmm I also picture them doing that as
well sitting on a stack of cash butt
naked
wait sorry this is my fault sorry top 30
under 30 top 40 under 40 there you go
I'll be butt naked for that
when I see it yes everybody would like
pinching her on the cover of Forbes
magazine my picture on the cover of
Playboy magazine stop picturing these
chicks that are more successful than me
no I'm just no I want them all you up I
just want them all the way to do well
it's not an angle for me to get laid
more what do I need to be more
successful for you to look at me oh my
god am I not gonna be on farms magazine
as you get older I think as a guy you
tend to get more annoyed of women so
it's like when I was younger I used to
just like Danica so as I'm older I'm
like you were like a headache
you look [ __ ] annoying well you also
didn't go up with a lot of sisters yeah
that's probably what it is but like it's
like there's like a discernible quality
that happened I don't just like look at
women just as a this thing it's more
like you're pretty but you could also be
a [ __ ] [ __ ] but when you're young
and single and you don't have much
relationship experience you put women on
a pedestal yeah because you create this
imagination of like how great it will be
and then you actually get in a
relationship and you go oh [ __ ] women do
that too though women always idealize
like what it would be like to have a
boyfriend and like oh he's it would be
such a good boyfriend because he's cute
and he'd be a boyfriend and then you
he's your boyfriend and he's I didn't
the girls girls cause guys are jerks yes
they go do that thing I don't think it's
a just one gender thing it's like being
single - longfang huh yeah and watching
too many romance movies where you're
like oh that's how it is when people are
together guys and in real life they're
like like oh I have to go have sex with
my husband that I know I know you do by
it that's true for a lot of people
though yeah damn how sad a lot to look
forward to kids yay
hey you just become smarter that's all
yeah just don't get married till you
find the date you want